hey everyone this is kevin from
thechestwebsite.com and today we're
going to be continuing our series of the
1996 battle between
man verse machine that is gary kasparov
at the time of 96 he was the world
champion
and he's facing off against the ibm
supercomputer known as
deep blue before this series
a supercomputer had never beaten a world
chess champion at classical chess
meaning just the
think of the longer chess games super
computer
never beaten a human so 1996
these players battle it out we have
already gone over
the first two games in the series if you
haven't checked those out already i have
a link in the description below
i also have a youtube playlist that i'll
make sure shows up as well
you can check those out but today we're
going to be looking at game number three
from that series just make sure you
understand
how we got here in game one deep blue
playing the white pieces
played the alpine opening versus the
sicilian defense from gare kasparov
and deep blue went on to win that game
the first time a super computer had ever
beaten a world champion
was in this match right here game number
one gary kasparov came back in game
number two
and said we're not gonna be doing this
i'm the world champion here and he
ended up winning game number three which
brings us to
game number three that we're going to be
looking at today
so white's going to be played by d blue
the super computer
black's going to be played by garrick
sparrow of the world champion
deep blue starts out with e4 gear
responds with a c5 the sicilian and then
pawn to c3 this is exactly how deep blue
started out in game number one this is
the alpine
variation in the sicilian defense if you
haven't already seen the video on this
opening i do have a video already made
have a link in the description below but
that'll let you know understand
how this opening actually plays out as
many people view it as the anti-sicilian
but it has success in game number one so
hey why not go back to
the same opening that won for the ibm
super computer
gecko sprout plays d5 usually going to
be playing knight to f6
or d5 both are pretty common here
these are all the same lines that we saw
in game number one
in fact they even repeated the same
moves all the way to
move number seven so after the queen
takes here
pawn up here to d4 knight to f6 knight
to f3
bishop down here to g4 and after bishop
to e2
upon e6 we see castle on the king side
from deep blue now in game number one
where white went on to win that game
we saw h3 and after the bishop comes
back here
castle on the king side knight to c6
just to getting all the material
involved into the game bishop to e3
pawn takes pawn takes and then the
bishop's going to come down here to
b4 we see a lot of that in game three as
well the only difference is we don't see
that h3 move from d blue instead
white decides just to go and castle on
the king side but the rest of the moves
continue
just like they did in game number one
bishop here to e3
pawn takes in the center pawn recaptures
bishop here to a b4 and now pawn to a3
forcing the bishop to come back here to
a five
d blue continues with knight two c3 just
developing material towards the center
of the board attacking the queen queen
comes back to
d6 now in game number one deep blue
continue to push up the board with
knight to b5
changing things up a little bit instead
plays knight to e5 has the outpost here
with the pawn on
d4 exchange here on e2 bishops come off
the board after queen to e2
kyrgyzstab says bishop takes here on a
c3
both my bishops i want them off the
board gary krispov is
not having it wants to get rid of those
bishops as fast as possible
he's the world champion he can do
whatever he wants to pawn captures here
on
c3 so there's now a backwards pawn
here for black to attack for the rest of
the game
but this position is pretty complicated
and gary chris prov continues with
knight takes here on
e5 so exchanging more minor pieces
a lot of players would look at this and
say okay you took my knight i'm gonna
recapture your knight
that makes a lot of sense but then just
black takes here
and blacks up material not only is black
up material but they have a much better
structure going into the end game white
has
three pawn structures and black has two
it's much easier to defend
two pawn structures and also they have
pawns
next to each other to help support as
they push up the board
deep blue is going to have a tough spot
in this position but
deep blue being a super computer as high
level chess players they recognize that
pawn takes on e5 is not the best move
and instead
white can play bishop to f4
because the knight can't move it's being
pinned down
by the bishop to the queen here so black
has a couple options
one you could see maybe queen two c6
removing the pin on the queen and also
attacking this pawn here on
c3 but then you just continue maybe
bishop takes here
maybe the rook comes over here you don't
want to do anything else because if
if this knight moves for some reason
maybe knight to d7 then all of a sudden
the bishop takes here on g7 that's kind
of difficult for
black um even if you play rook 2 g8
rook 2 or queen 2 g4 i think it's a
tough spot
for black so maybe instead rook to
c8 just getting it to the semi-open file
attacking
uh this pawn here that we already said
on
c3 but then after the exchange uh
double pawns here on the f file not as
bad since that's coming towards the
center of the board but now black has
three pawn structures white has three
pawn structures not all that bad rook to
b1 attacking this pawn here on
b7 that's how play could have continued
if the queen came to c6 another option
is to
uh just move this knight you could play
knight to f3 check
but then that doesn't get you in a
better position
in my opinion queen takes here on uh
f3 queen two d5 uh maybe queen over here
to d3
instead i really like the option of
knight to
d7 this still protects this knight here
on e5
so if they were to take with their pawn
we could just bring the queen back here
to a c7
now as far as material both sides are
equal but
i think that black has a better end game
because of the three pawn structures
uh this just seems like a good spot
queen here on c7 attacking this
isolated pawn here on the c file i think
this is good for black if
instead the bishop just takes here on e5
when al just knight takes pawn takes and
then queen to
c5 attacking both of these pawns same
concept as before now garcia sparrow
solved a little bit differently than me
and that's okay because he's a lot
better than i am at chess
he decided in this position to play
knight two
f three after the queen takes here on
f3 queen to d5 so gary kasparov
maybe he's just looking to exchange
material he lost game one remember
when deep blue played the alpine and so
maybe he's just saying let's get all
this material off the board let's get a
draw
and let's pack it in i have the white
pieces going into game number four
and i expect to win that game queen over
here to
d3 rook to c8 attacking this pawn that
we talked about was going to be a threat
for black for the rest of the game
and then rook here to c1
garrick spav continues with queen to c4
just saying please please exchange
queens on the board
that's exactly what we get from deep
blue rook comes down here takes here on
c4 rook to b1 attacking the pawn up here
because power responds with
pawn to b6 and this is much better than
just taking this material right here
black takes on c3
rook takes on b7 and then how does black
really
continue this pawn is under attack right
here
it's very difficult for black to really
hold on to that castle on the king side
and then lose the pawn on a7
that's just not really that good from
black so instead gerov
correctly plays just pawn to
b6 bishop up here to b8 attacking the
pawn
rook swings over here to a4 rook to b4
could exchange caspar brings his rook
back here to a5
rook to c4 so deeply doing a good job of
getting all their material involved
into the game especially in the center
of the board it's very nice to see how
they maneuver their
rooks all over the board bishop down
here to d6
rook to a8 another option i think
kasparov had is to play rook 2 e8
yes you can bring it over here and
defend on the a file but
rook to e8 is a central square for the
rook
can start to push forward with material
at any given time
and also it's on a light square this
dark square bishop is never going to be
able to
attack this rook at all so i think this
makes a lot of sense as far as where
that rook
can go but instead comes over here to a8
and then rook to c6
kasparov plays pawn to b5
and then king to f1 once the queens
comes off the board you're usually going
to see the kings get involved into the
game that's exactly what happens right
here so king to f1
rook down to a4 rook to
b1 attacking this pawn here on b5
pawn to a6 protecting that pawn king to
e2 so deep blue
very much so getting that king involved
into the game pond h5 attacking on the
king side of the board
king to d3 super computers not too
worried about the pawn on the king side
rook 2 d8 attacking the bishop and
just being in the center of the board
bishop to e7 as we said before
you put that rook on the dark square and
that bishop can easily attack it here
rook 2 d7 attacking the knights are
attacking the bishop and the bishop just
decides to go ahead and exchange with
the knight here so pawn takes on f6 and
then rook
to b3 defending both these pawns here on
the third rank
king 2 g7 we are now in a double
rook in game i may do a series on double
rook in games
if you guys are interested in that uh
always thinking of series that i can do
i do plan on doing a lot more in-game
series but this one
you may be interested in king 2 e3
pawn e5 just trying to blow up the
center of the board g3
there is an exchange in the center of
the board rook 2 e7
check king over here to f3 rook to d7
attacking the pawn in the center rook
over here to
d3 we do see an exchange and then
rook over here to a six
pawn to b4 and the players
or the player and the machine uh in the
team that kind of runs the ibm
supercomputer agree to a draw
in this position if we look at it
definitely seems like a draw
uh no one has a past pawn uh you know
black has more central control
also has double pawns on the file it's
going to be very difficult for
either side to get a victory here so
they do draw
going into game number four where gary
christopher will have the white pieces
we are all tied remember deep blue
winning game one gerard winning game two
and now a draw
in game number three for man verse
machine
so hopefully you guys enjoyed this video
let me know what you think
in the comments below if you made it all
all the way to the end of the video if
you wouldn't mind putting a hundred
at the end of your comment that'll let
me know that you made it all the way
through
have made a few changes in the video
people asked that i put
the uh respective player under the board
so they could tell who is white who is
black let me know what you guys think of
that i am always looking to improve the
video
um so you can tell that i'm reading the
comments and making adjustments
also heard some feedback around the
lining up of voice and video let me know
if that is good as well if there's
other series you want me to do after
deep blue i think i have a couple more
games to do in the series let me know
i'm definitely looking for a
longer series that i can analyze but
thank you guys so much for watching
watching the video and i'll see you guys
next time